hey everybody welcome to metaphysical
milkshake i'm reza aslan and i am rain
wilson
i'm sorry what's happening i
am rain wilson oh look it's the innodium
p23
explosive space modulator i i i don't i
what is going did you sit on your balls
what is happening here
oh you're doing the bugs bunny guy
in the martian i have been cast in the
live-action version of marvin the
martian
movie is that oh my is that true is that
happening this is happening
well i'm auditioning but that's what i
see happening i mean with that that act
you did it you did it it's yours the the
it's an excellent
space modulator
wait i imagine that to get the job you
have to first become an expert on all
things mars right i mean maybe that
would help that that might be important
maybe some research did you know
that the ancient sumerians actually were
obsessed with mars they they uh they
called it the wandering star wow they
thought that it it
pretended all kinds of like malevolent
you know prophecies about what's
happening on earth and the romans named
mars after the god of war or was the god
of war named after the planet mars how
did that work i'm pretty sure it was the
the planet was named after the god of
war i don't know what the romans called
the planet but i know that like the
romans were upset the greeks
had like all kinds of uh associations
with like the god of war and and all
that stuff so that you know the romans
borrowed it from them but also in the in
the new world uh in the in the mythology
of the aztecs as well absolutely and the
maya look i mean here's the bottom line
is that we as a species have been
obsessed with mars for a very long time
i mean all my my favorite
uh you know uh 20th century uh sci-fi
books movies they all involve mars uh it
has loomed large in the human
imagination
since the get-go since we were that's
right building fires late at night in
caves and there was no unobstructed
there was no light pollution in the sky
and we saw that that little
red dot
following the sun crossing the sky
um
mars is lit yo
i remember reading the martian
chronicles when i was a kid and thinking
to myself like this is a this is a thing
like we could actually
we could actually go to mars like that's
a that's real that's a real thing you
know like that could actually happen and
here we are we're sending probes up
there we're sending you know these like
helicopters that fly around mars and
everyone's just like
well let's do this like let's go to mars
but let's just go to mars also brings up
a lot of questions reza i mean should we
go to mars even if we learn that it
already supports its own living
organisms
since our time left on earth might be
finite do we even have the moral right
to explore
other planets
welcome to metaphysical milkshake the
show where we go deep we get weird and
we search for the meaning of life along
the way presented by cast media and soul
pancake
these questions are just too big rain
like there's no way how are we ever
going to find a get we'd have to find
someone whose entire job would be to be
i don't know something like a i don't
know like a planetary protection
specialist but that's not a real job
that's like a job that you have you just
made that up a planetary protection
specialist
i've never heard of that before wait
hold on i'm hearing something wait we
we've got one what no
yeah the producers are telling me that
we have a planetary protection
specialist who works for nasa no it's
not dr muga cooper is it
in fact it is amazing she is an american
astronomer in the lead of planetary
protection for the mars 2020 mission
that's right she has a graduate doctoral
degrees in mechanical engineering she
graduated high school at the age of 16
and then got her phd at 24. like la dee
da big deal impressive i'm not i'm not
impressed yeah well i got my ged at 27
so
uh her dissertation focused on
non-equilibrium plasma sterilization of
spacecraft materials which is weird
because that's almost what i wrote my
dissertation on but really you know yeah
last minute i was like no she's been
working as a planetary protection
engineer at jpl since 2010 and appeared
in 33 episodes of how the universe works
let's welcome dr moon and welcome to the
show
um
the impressive space modulator dr moo
dr moo thank you so much for joining us
does anyone ever ask you
about like your opinions on cow science
on cow science no
although now i feel like i've been
cheated many great conversations
i don't think people with unusual names
should be
uh insulted on this show okay rain and
reza and dr moo that's true that's true
we are unique individual souls also i
would imagine most people you talk to
are more sophisticated than we are so no
i i hear the whole gamut you know
my name has been smushed with all types
of words so
i've heard it so you are a and this is a
true thing this is i didn't make this up
this is actually a real job you are a
planetary protection engineer
which
sounds like
something uh a red shirt in star trek
would do no thankfully we're not one of
the red shirts we we survive from
mission emission
um okay
um yeah in fact the the analogy i've
been using these days uh are we're the
modern day the real life guardians of
the galaxy that's actually way cooler
than they wouldn't technically be red
shirts they would be blue shirts because
they'd work in the science division
under spock oh nerd oh come in correct
speaking of nerds you are you are quite
quite a prominent nerd yourself dr mu so
for the non-nerds
uh in the audience very few of them uh
could you explain to us what exactly is
a planetary protection engineer yeah a
planetary protection engineer is a
person who is
in charge of making sure that the
spacecraft that we're sending out it
could be a spacecraft going to to mars
to europa to um the moons of jupiter uh
other moons of jupiter um to make sure
that when we send the spacecraft out
that it is clean enough so that it
doesn't inadvertently spread our
earth-borne microbes out to that
environment that we're trying to explore
so that you don't like uh infect
the
whatever you know the life forms the
biosphere the eggs it's like it's like a
primitive prime directive it is star
trek exactly yeah that's what but we're
not the red shirts though
right but it is the prime directive and
to not interfere with the potential
life or even lack of life on another
planet because you don't want some dumb
astronaut who dropped a sandwich on the
floor and then it flies over to europa
and lands
and the there's a green mold and then it
gets onto the
dirt of europa and then everyone thinks
oh my god we've got foreign life that
looks just like this common kitchen mold
from
uh from florida i think i've actually
seen that episode but yeah you've seen
actually echo these ecological impacts
right in different sides of the good
side and the bad side there's a good
ecological impact i know some of you out
there i'm sure i have right i've had
kombucha i've eaten activia um and that
has a that's a positive ecological
impact of a microbe going in an
environment that's new and it does good
things right probiotics but then you've
seen the negative side when you ate
maybe a sandwich that stayed out on the
table too long
and you've got food poisoning so that's
a negative ecological impact so since
you if we don't know we can't predict if
we're going to have a positive or
negative impact so the goal is don't
spread our contaminants at all okay i'm
sorry but that seems like a cool job
does that not seem like a cool job to
you rain it sounds boring and and it
sounds like it sounds like you use a lot
of like lysol basically and that's all
she does she basically sprays the ships
with lysol i'm more interested in your
story um you you got your phd at age 24.
you graduated from high school at 16.
show off and
what brought you i know you're not in
any way shape or form any kind of
spokesperson for nasa um but what
brought you to nasa and working on mars
expeditions
let us know a little bit about yourself
and your personal story in history yeah
the reason why you you read all of those
young ages you know when i started uh
high school and college and and
graduated with my phd it's because i'm a
very impatient person
um and
when i was a kid i saw carl sagan's the
cosmos and that turned my light bulb on
i was poor in math and in science and in
reading
still don't read as much as i should uh
but i i was that those were my least
favorite subjects and it was that moment
that
allowed me to put it all together and
say oh this is why my math class and my
science classes are important and from
then on i just spent every single summer
while all the other kids
had summer vacations i was taking summer
classes to double up on my my math
courses and just graduate as soon as
possible so that i can eventually go to
nasa and and make some major changes and
understand how our universe works are we
alone in this big vast universe this is
amazing like you
you knew exactly what you wanted to do
and then you like pursued it and like
you're literally there right now doing
that
so that's very inspiring so planetary
protections uh dr mu are strictly
enforced right now but one of the things
reza and i were talking about before
this interview is
what about when the space exploration
opens up to commercial companies which
is going to happen um how can we ensure
the same measures are in place to avoid
contaminating other planets with our
sandwich germs yeah
exactly is there some kind of
international imperative uh law that
needs to be passed yeah there actually
is already an international treaty the
the space act treaty 1967
space act treaty um and in that treaty
that it essentially lays the foundation
of planetary protection so as the united
united states is one of the signatories
of that treaty so we have to abide by it
and commercial entities
technically have to abide by those
policies to make sure that when they
explore they do it also in a responsible
manner the thing is you know nasa itself
isn't a regulatory agency we need we
need a the carrot and we need a stick
nasa's not a stick
um so we have to there's kind of a gap
there where you need to really
incentivize the companies to really
follow through with that and there's
been a push lately to to make planetary
protection more accessible
cheaper more robust so that they can
easily implement that for their flight
projects and not worry about the bottom
line wait okay so
how do you incentivize this how do you
incentivize
you know spacex or whatever to
follow the rules yeah one way is you
know
making sure that when they get the award
to say this is what we're going to be
looking for right
otherwise no space for you and yeah no
space for you you go back in the corner
and
think about what you've done um yeah and
and beyond that those are the main ways
it's a list of one
right i mean it's just the right thing
to do and you have to have that self
motivation you have to have those values
as a company to to know that as you
explore that you you're putting a lot of
things in jeopardy if you don't do it in
the proper way do you want that on your
on your back on your shoulder sure sure
and of course as we all know people like
jeff bezos elon musk all about values
all about integrity nothing to worry
about doing what's right
all about doing what's right you guys
let's shift the discussion here thank
you so much but let's shift it to what
we all really want to talk about which
is mars mars you were involved in the
mars 2020 mission um tell us about what
you did and what makes this mission so
different than the ones before it yeah
so i was the planetary protection lead
for the mars 2020 mission and that meant
that it was my job to really ensure that
i was the person that stood on the
chopping block and said yes this
spacecraft is clean enough to to push
the launch button um and and then of
course people above me sign the right
papers to push the button
um but we learned so much in the past
you might be wondering why are we
sending another rover to mars i know you
two aren't because you love mars so much
um but this this perseverance rover has
stood on the robotic shoulders of its
predecessors we knew from the last rover
missions that there is great geology
there interesting geology there is a
habitable environment and there is signs
of water uh and so the next thing to do
is look for signs of life at least
ancient life and that's what this this
rover is going to do this is really what
we wanted to to talk to you about was
obviously mars and
i mean and this is this is i think most
people around the world not just here in
the united states share the the
obsession that rain and i have uh about
the red planet and
and i'm curious like what do you think
that's all about i mean there are entire
religions right that are based on
obsession with mars i mean you go back
to ancient history the ancient sumerians
right the first great civilization
uh in in human history um had so many of
their rituals and their and their
mythologies focused on
um uh mars and and the the rising and
falling of mars this is true the mayans
of course the greeks loved mars
um i mean mars
has been a
an obsession for like science fiction
obviously yeah which is kind of the new
religion of the modern world it's true
uh science fiction uh mars attacks h.g
wells war of the worlds invading
martians uh as soon as we could we had
telescopes that was one of the first
things obviously after the moon that we
zoomed in on we could see that it was
another planet um it goes on and on the
martian chronicles yeah right
we were just talking about this earlier
like all our favorite mars
movies and books and everything but
so the obsession is obvious including
that documentary called the martian with
matt damon
he's still there is he i hope he's okay
folks when it comes to losing weight uh
there is a lot of pressure out there to
label foods either good foods or bad
foods but you know what that's just
creating unnecessary dilemmas well guess
what nume is here to change how we see
food and they do it with a psychology
based approach that looks at what you
eat but also how you eat so instead of
trying to cram your life into someone
else's idea of health try new nume uses
a psychology-based approach to find a
healthier balance that's you know
moldable to your life my good buddy ben
he swears by noob he used it i mean he's
he's transformed his body reza this
guy's lost like 20 he went never like
what i would call like overweight but he
has slimmed down tremendously and he he
swears by the way that it works because
it just brings extra consciousness and
information to your choices around food
it's not a diet plan it is uh
a new way of interacting with food the
idea that i don't need rules in order to
lose weight but instead you know
knowledge wisdom uh the ability to just
kind of build smarter more sustainable
eating habits so start building better
habits for healthier long-term results
sign up for your trial at noom.com
that's
n-o-o-m-dot-com
milkshake
n-o-o-m.com
milkshake
noom.com you know we've mentioned this a
few times on the podcast part of the
reason why we even do this is because
rain and i love learning all the time
like we just
i mean we're just you know we're sponges
we just want to learn constantly with
albeit as little effort as
possible that's true that's why
we love wandrium i mean
it is the streaming service that our
brains can't get enough of there's so
much to explore we absolutely love it
love it if you're unfamiliar with one
wandriam it offers endless opportunities
to learn something new with thousands of
hours of video and audio content which
include fascinating documentaries uh
helpful how to's one dream let me spell
it for you w-o-n-d-r-i-u-n
one dream i love watching and it makes
me feel good it makes my mind buzz and
click and flip out
and uh i've been having so much fun
watching crimes of the century
a selective history of infamy
the plot to assassinate the russian
romanov family is fascinating i'm
telling you
it is so addictive we know you'll love
one dream so we put together a special
offer for our listeners a free month
trial of unlimited access just go to our
special url
that's one dream dot com slash milkshake
that's wondrian
w-o-n-d-r-i-u-m
dot com slash milkshake think of how
much you'll learn in a month go to
onedrive.com
milkshake combined with metaphysical
milkshake
and your mind will blossom like a rose
well you quoted uh carl sagan earlier
and we have a lot of handy-dandy carl
sagan quotes because he apparently yeah
he had a lot to say about he had a lot
to say about everything but especially
mars and we're talking about mars living
so large in the cultural imagination he
said maybe we're on mars because we have
to be because there's a deep nomadic
impulse built into us by the
evolutionary process we all come from
from hunter-gatherers i'm transforming
into sagan and for
99.9 of our tenure on earth we've been
wanderers and the next place to wander
to
is mars
spot on
it's pretty good i like it yeah i love
it but then it kind of sparks the whole
ethical side about uh how to responsibly
wander to other places well so there you
go let's go there you know obviously
this is the new obsession now we're
talking about not just exploring mars
colonizing we're talking about
colonizing mars exactly like let's let's
go there and let's live there and
there's a whole bunch of reasons why we
would or we wouldn't and all that
but i mean i do
what what carl sagan says
sort of
makes sense to me like at a deep um you
know psychological level like he's right
i mean 99.9
of our existence as a species has been
about
wandering and and um and sort of
exploring new worlds and so
you know it kind of makes sense to think
that well now that we've basically used
up you know our planet that the next
place to go is into space and to to
other worlds so there's all this
excitement now and everyone's talking
about
what do we do are we going to colonize
mars what's what's what's what's going
to happen when we get there
and we can talk about
you know the the feasibility of it in
fact let's start there that's uh before
we get to the moral question okay
uh i think that there is a sense among
some you know
amateur enthusiasts uh space enthusiasts
that like th this [ __ ] is happening like
we're all gonna be moving to mars uh any
day now first first elon
and then the rest of us prove us wrong
prove that wrong apparently it's
slightly more complicated that's what
i've heard yeah yeah i'm gonna get my
blanket and get it uh doubt some water
on it because i'm going to throw a wet
blanket on this whole thing
i thought you meant like a blanket for
the trip yeah like a space blanket first
of all i love
i would never want to truly be a wet
blanket to those who are having these
conversations because i think it could
stem a lot of innovative thoughts
because you you have to bridge the gap
between how where we are right now and
how to get to that final point and there
are many many steps to get there so i
think it's great that we're talking
about it the feasibility of doing that
if you could say are we going to do it
in the next 10 20 30 years i would say
probably not oh what a bummer so and why
do you say no yeah the reason why so our
our bodies we're very sensitive
organisms uh
just
going into space changes our body there
was that the twin experiment right where
we had twin astronauts one state went up
to the is international space station
one state on the ground and just testing
the down to the genetic material you can
see changes that were already starting
to happen
and those changes weren't necessarily
all for the best
uh and as you float in in the
environment of space your muscles
atrophy you have to find ways to solve
that your heart is one of your biggest
or
i wouldn't say most important muscles
but it's a very important muscle um and
you got to keep working those things out
and right now there aren't
i would say you could survive on mars
for a bit but you won't be thriving
if we were to send someone to mars
there's just so many things to
understand
and that's why the artemis program which
is the nasa's initiative to send
astronauts to the moon first and have it
be a test bed first
is a really great idea because i think
there's so many dots to connect
that we need to start cut a little bit
more locally and really vet it while
we're a little bit closer to home just
in case something happens well
let me jump in here because this is my
opinion about this whole settle settling
mars and why i think the movie uh the
documentary the martian with matt damon
is so preposterous like oh we just need
a nice tent with some ferns and some
carrots and potatoes and a nice space
suit and we'll all be fine it's like an
astronaut poop and poop poop potatoes
listen it's easy it's surface
temperatures of 80 below zero no
breathable air no protection from
radiation from the sun people would have
to live underground no magnetic field
which we talked about um it can get down
to 200 below zero
and the atmospheric pressure forget the
air is thinner it's mostly carbon
monoxide dioxide and uh it goes on
gravity is only 40 of that on earth
so the it's it's it is a nightmare this
kind of like
utopian vision of like these little
space pods and and hydroponic gardens is
is preposterous i don't know i mean i
feel like i've had worse vacations that
that's not so tell us dr mu why you say
exactly tell us why from your experience
no i mean i completely agree and and
there are people looking at creative
ways to solve these issues but yeah
you're right there are not only the
human factors that i pointed out but
like you were saying the environmental
constraints do you really want to it's
not easy to build a habitat to survive
those high radiation
uh low temperature environments i mean
you're being constantly bombarded by all
of this uv it's it's not pleasant
so yeah it's not
there's a lot of instant gratification
maybe that you see from tv shows and
from movies but that's not how it works
in real life we have a long way to go
how many years till we send a human
being to mars what do you think again do
you want this person to survive or to
thrive it depends on who the person is
i mean i think honestly you know i love
that answer
what about all these astronauts that are
um
talking about going and just dying on
mars and being buried on mars that just
seems kind of macabre and weird doesn't
it you could see earth as a little blip
out in the and the horizon and you're
like i'm dying on another planet is that
cool or is that kind of [ __ ] up yeah i
mean i could see that there are a group
of people who just the the the notoriety
maybe the the fact that they're going to
be written in the history books forever
um might be enough of a motivation for
them to go there and just die
and that would kind of with the state of
technology be the extent of what they
can do
is go and die um but yeah the goal and
with each step for example with this
this mars 2020 rover
one of the instruments that it has is a
moxie instrument it converts the co2 to
oxygen and because right now there's no
sustainable way of even having
breathable air let's start with air
kind of important right so we need ways
to have a sustainable infrastructure and
right now
we we just don't have it so sending a
person there
is going to be tough and once they get
there there's not a lot for them to
to stay protected unless
they land in an area where there are
lava tubes so that's one of the places
they're creatively looking at again
rain as you said it's ridiculously cold
you know 80 below
and that's at the highest temperature
that's that's on a warm day that's a
good day um
it's just
you can't look at that as the the silver
bullet and say yeah forget about our
planet let's let's move on to another
body we really need to take care of our
own blue marble because there's just way
too many steps between now and sending
humans to mars living there thriving
surviving enjoying well all right so now
now we're getting to
the heart of this right which is the
less that the technological and
pragmatic issues involved in uh in
colonizing mars and more sort of the
moral and ethical issues involved and
you brought up one of the main things
that people always talk about which is
um usually conversations
about you know colonizing or settling on
mars
have something to do with the fact that
well
we [ __ ] up this planet and uh and we
should probably figure out you know
another planet like someplace else to
to to start again which even even as i
say that out loud i mean you could
obviously tell like the moral
implications
of that statement and yet it is
something that you hear
a lot right i mean this is what what you
know elon musk who by the way has said
that he does want to die on mars and i'm
like cool that's
i think we're all totally cool with you
dying on mars elon
um
so he's this is his whole thing right
that it's like look
you know we are facing
these kind of existential problems here
uh
on this planet and if we want our
species to survive it's time to look to
the stars
and over and beyond what you said about
like you know the the actual pragmatic
you know possibilities of that
uh
there's something really [ __ ] up about
that that mindset isn't there i mean
like theoretically it sounds nice
but no we really need to take care of
our own planet and and it's interesting
because as i talk to to folks about
space and and space exploration i get a
lot of well why are you spending money
on space and where are you just shooting
money into uh throwing loading rockets
with money and throwing it in into
outward space it's like oh that's not
what we do and many of the missions
actually that explore uh our our space
environment are turned toward the earth
and learning more about our carbon
footprint about fires and how they
spread
about you know urban population growth i
mean this is all
nasa data right it is telling us about
our own planet and how we can do a
better job at protecting it and i'm i'm
so glad i mean that that's that's i
think the reason for the season we need
a planet to live on really what you're
saying is there's a difference between
science and kind of space colonization
slash imperialism you know it it reminds
me of that what's that what do we learn
in american history that divine
imperative to like colonize the west
uh uh manifest destiny manifest destiny
like we have a manifest destiny to
conquer these planets now
if there's not a shred of life on mars
and i mean like not a bacterium or a
germ that's one thing we could have that
discussion there's still plenty of
discussion to have but you know carl
sagan again said if there is life on
mars i believe we should do nothing with
mars mars then belongs to the martians
even if the martians are only microbes
and there has been
a movement
among people to say hey if there's any
kind of life on this planet which is
kind of your job by the way um kind of
your job related to your job um then we
shouldn't we shouldn't go there and
you know interestingly enough the the
political right the national review
wrote an article about how
uh
entitled wokists
assault space exploration like oh how
dare we go you know we might step on the
germ on mars but what's you what's your
take on this yeah it was because of carl
sagan that we actually have a lot of our
planetary protection rules and policies
and one of his big contributions is a
probability of ten to the minus four so
one in ten thousand of contaminating
mars and that was the upper limit that's
the probability when as we're sending
all these spacecraft to mars that was
the maximum limit when we would
calculate how likely is it that this
cesspool would contaminate mars it had
to be at or below one in ten thousand
and so he really helped shape the the
rules and the policies that we abide by
today uh in order to protect even the
microorganisms so that we can do this
again responsibly ethically um and to be
cognizant and fair uh to possible life
on different planets
it's the right thing to do
folks listen times are tough out there
and if you're carrying a credit balance
month after month it can feel like
you're in a never-ending cycle of debt
so upstart can help you make that final
payment so you can get ahead if you
dread looking at your credit card
statements you're not alone debt can
feel crippling but upstart can help you
on your path to financial freedom over a
half a million people have used upstart
to get one
fixed monthly payment how delicious is
that i remember so clearly the day when
i like paid off my debts
it was the greatest feeling it was like
having this weight just removed from my
chest i cried when i paid off my student
loans i looked at the world in a
different way find out how upstart can
lower your monthly payments today when
you go to upstart.com milkshake that's
upstart.com
milkshake don't forget to use our url to
let them know that we sent you loan
amounts will be determined based on your
credit income and certain other
information provided in your loan
application but go to upstart.com
milkshake give it a try
it reminds me one of my favorite songs
modest mouse lampshades on fire
where the lampshades on fire when the
lights go out and the rooms lit up and
we ran about
this is what i really call a party now
packed up by cars move to the next town
this song is actually it sounds like a
party song you've probably heard it on
the radio a thousand times you know know
what my terrible rendition really means
but i will say the lyrics go pack up
again head to the next place where we'll
make the same mistakes and um
uh isaac brock one of my favorite human
beings on the planet is uh was talking
about this song is actually about
climate change and about um how you know
we'll destroy life on earth and then
we'll go to mars but but this leads me
to another great song which is david
bowie
tell me is there life on mars
um
and
if there is
dr mu
one germ one bacterium on mars then
there is
life on other planets this is not just
like reza said also what do we step on
some bacteria who cares and i know you
were saying that as a devil's advocate
but
if there is something on another planet
that is proof
that life exists on other planets i mean
we kind of already know there's got to
be life on other planets i mean come on
be reasonable but
that would be the biggest discovery of
the eon to find a simple
single cell bacteria on mars would it
not
it would and it would jeopardize our
ability to do that as soon as we send
humans there and that's why it's so
important to really understand the
astrobiological landscape of mars before
we start you know contaminating it with
with people what about a tv show about a
lonely android who's sent to the surface
of mars and he walks around all by
himself then he gets sad it's very sad
like circuits too cold powering down
soaring music
pan back reveal him all alone frozen on
the martian landscape tear pan back even
further there's the statue of liberty it
was earth the whole time the whole time
it was earth
oh my god reza that's good [ __ ] write
this down somebody write this down okay
what you just said is is super important
because it's an amazing response to
the devil's argument that i was making
which is you know it's microbe versus
you know
unimaginable
advantages uh for humans
but it's not just a microbe
it is the
overturning of every human philosophy of
what it means to be human what it means
to be alive how we understand
uh the universe and god and the
relationship between god and i mean
like the the first piece of bacteria we
find on mars changes
everything like everything has to be
rewritten
and so
the the concept of doing whatever it
takes to preserve that microbial life
isn't a utilitarian argument any longer
it's a theological and philosophical
argument i mean it's it's basically
you know the the
the value of what it means to be human
is what's at stake in how we
deal with the thing that we find
regardless of how
undeveloped that life is exactly wow you
took it there that's great
so deep i i never even thought about the
theological side implications
of finding life elsewhere yeah that
that's a fantastic point but let's get
let's get down to it isn't ultimately
the reason that people want to
explore mars
i mean nasa aside gathering science
learning okay fine but as soon as you
get into colonization i mean let's just
get down to brass tacks we're human
beings we're we would be going to mars
because we want to exploit it
isn't this what you know whether it's
nasa now but private companies in the
future or governments or you know north
korea sends a a fleet of spaceships
there in the year 2300 or something like
that like um
what is lost ethically when space
exploration gets commercialized and it's
going to be commercial let's just be
clear about this nasa can't afford
to send people to mars only bezos can
afford something like that so it's going
to be commercialized anyway yeah well
and that's the beauty of having the
commercial entity versus the government
sector right but that i've been asked in
the past right well are you competitors
uh what is the need what what is the
niche for each part and the government
so the nasa side nasa will still
continue to send for example humans to
the beyond to the next frontier because
nasa focuses on
what do we do to push our limits of
understanding it may not result in
something that is profitable or maybe
even applicable to anyone on earth but
many of the technologies do
eventually have an application that
really does help the people of earth out
significantly but nasa's goal is really
to
do the things that other people can't do
and then once the technology is
developed then you can give it to
commercial entities to make it faster
better cheaper
affordable for others to exploit
i'm just saying like you know
what once once zuckerberg lands on mars
and dubs it planet facebook
like he's bigger than any government
agency he's bigger than any government
uh you know he's richer than any
government and so
i i just feel like
how what what can little nasa do
to
control and create the the
responsibility that we all know is going
to be secondary to these you know
commercial enterprises
um to make sure that we don't you know
do what like the the european
colonialists did when they encountered
native populations which is just
accidentally kill everyone yeah and this
is where i look toward the next
generation because
i just based on what i've seen these
days you know recently politically i'm
just like well i i lost hope in the in
this group of people yeah
so i i just hope that with all of the
things that we're learning as we explore
space that it just grows the heart
and the minds of the next generation so
that they can fix
uh all of these gaps that exist right
now that will unfortunately allow
uh commercial entities to kind of run
away with it um and and maybe even you
know not not necessarily have planetary
protection in mind for example as they
explore
that needs to be changed
policy takes a long time to change and
i'm just hoping that the next generation
will help keep the last generation kind
of in check and say no we gotta we gotta
do better if you were a half mile under
the surface of mars would you be warmed
by the core of mars it wouldn't be balmy
but that doesn't matter for other forms
of life here on earth for example we
there are these things called
extremophiles that i i love to study and
my colleagues love to study these are
microbes that can survive in very
extreme environments and we learn the
more that we learn about those microbes
the more it expands our understanding of
where life could persist and exist
and so there are environments that we've
simulated martian environments on the
earth where there are some microbes that
are not happy again not thriving but
surviving can i give you a fun fact
about another place that we should look
at are you going to talk about europa
because europa you're going to say
oh my god you don't even know how
obsessed i am with europa i think about
it like all the time which is weird
thing to say well it's covered in water
right it's covered in ice
ice and then water and then there's
water underneath and i'm telling you
there's like there's of course there's
like where there's water there's life
right doctor moo water equals life yeah
i mean the chance is very high what are
we doing tell us about okay
let's go to europa europa as you all
know moon of jupiter one of the many
many moons like it has many children um
but it's you know a little bit closer in
the inner circle there europa has this
due to because it's kind of it's much
closer to jupiter itself
as you can imagine as you orbit a planet
there are these things that these tidal
fluxes your if you are a planet
with the force of gravity as you go
around a a body will make you flex and
expand and that generates heat
and so there are these warm um
features underneath that thick layer of
ice that allows it to keep a nice liquid
water environment that is warmed up by
those those tidal forces those geologic
forces
and we have actually similar
environments here on earth we have if
you go into the oceans and go deep down
into certain regions you can find these
smoke stacks
where it's otherwise extremely cold but
you have these hot smoke sacs and if you
take a sample there you can find
microbial life surviving thriving
living it up okay so when are we going
to break the ice when are we when are we
going to let's let's just take a giant
bowling ball with a camera see i'm a
scientist we take a giant bowling ball
with a camera we drop it
and then that's it we're done we've
explored
europa even better following the uh
bowling ball with the camera then we
take a big uh
like one of those cargo containers
filled with dolphins
and we drop those in and then come back
in a thousand years and those dolphins
will have evolved and have a whole like
they'll be dolphin people they will be
worshipping the bowling ball
that of course that will be in their
temple because they're like where did
this bowling ball come from so uh
basically we're at this point now where
obviously we recognize the technological
uh challenges we understand and are at
least somewhat committed to the moral
obligations that we have but
as a scientist as an ethicist as you're
kind of looking at the very near future
do you see the human species as a
multi-planetary
species is that the inevitable
future that we are that we are facing as
a species i think that that is
definitely possible and and
are we heading for that direction
yes especially as propulsion systems
catch up right to enable that it's going
to be difficult for example to to send
something to mars it was about a
six-month cruise uh it could be
somewhere between six to nine months
just to get to our closest neighbor um
so there are advances in propulsion
systems happening that will help make
our ability to be multi-planetary um a
possibility but again it goes back to
that
you know that whole question of we are
we going to survive we can survive but
not thrive i mean we could go there for
exploration i don't think that we would
go there to call or other to other
planets to colonize i don't think we
should
um for for any long-term plan right to
survive um
versus having our own beautiful uh blue
marble here
uh so yeah
yes i could see that as an inevitable
future but again just for for exploring
and and seeing
just understanding more about our solar
system but not necessarily to colonize
and thrive and as our hero carl sagan
would say
there is nowhere else at least not in
the near future to which our species
could migrate visit yes settle
not yet like it or not for the moment
the earth is where we make our stand
[Music]
well dr mu thank you so much this has
been so fascinating but it is now time
for the lightning round lightning round
here we go if you could have lunch with
any scientist
fiction or non-fiction and you can't say
carl sagan because then we can't have
four carl sagan references
uh what who would that be
neil degrasse tyson
you know yeah you know that's fine just
make sure you have a a chaperone with
you that's all dr mu what was the
happiest day of your life whoo the
happiest day of my life uh when i gained
independence of my own person
that's such a loaded uh
knowing you when was that like 14 yeah
you were you were seven twelve shoot how
old was i uh twenty nine no eighteen
what is one eye opening experience every
person should have i kind of referred to
this a little bit earlier in our um
conversation but
just experience a different religion
than your own
because it opens your mind up to just a
different approach to kind of this the
same question what's uh one thing that a
lot most people like but that you can't
stand
oh man so many things i was gonna say
neil degrasse tyson but go ahead
uh bad puns
describe your soul in ten words or less
open to receiving
and finding joy in life
let's
go okay uh this is a serious question
who would make a better astronaut uh me
or rain oh
can i say that both of you because
you know human factors uh to be an
astronaut
you can't it's it's better to go with a
partner to have someone to balance you
because it's a long journey we could
podcast all the way to mars there you go
rain you know what rain you balance me
oh see it's the yin and the yang it's
like
you can't you can't pick one dr mu when
do you feel most connected with the
universe
i try to be at all times but for sure in
the morning when i wake up and i'm just
happy that i'm not dead
that sounds really morbid it's a great
thing wake up and be like ah not dead
great day there is something
incredibly miraculous about uh the
miracle of consciousness and your eyes
open up and you're like wow i'm online i
have thoughts and feelings and
perceptions i can do things i have i can
take action
and uh
what an incredible miracle that i get to
smell a flower or or throw a ball or
even have a conversation
exactly i agree
and on that note finally uh what is your
life's big question are we alone in this
universe
i mean it's kind of cheesy brings it
full circle but
that's that's what sparked my interest
and that's why i'm doing what i'm doing
wow thank you dr moo that was amazing
that was a deep dive yeah into mars i
don't know i got to be honest with you
like i'm still
i feel a little bit more optimistic
about humans going to mars than i think
uh dr moo uh was of course she's a
scientist and i'm not so what the hell
do i know but
wouldn't you move to mars if you could
i mean if it was safe i'm not saying
like it's you know you go there and it's
880 degrees below what is it 800 degrees
below zero what is it no it's it lingers
between 80 and 180 degrees below zero
well that ain't so bad
yeah you know where wear a scarf
just layer you have to layer layers it's
layers and also those little things you
crinkle up that make your gloves warm
the glove warmers okay let's assume you
can you can have like you know a biodome
there and like breathable atmosphere
yeah and uh and you know you you got
electric blankets is there ubereats
there so there's a shake shack but
that's it that's you have to have shake
shack morning tonight good choice by the
way if there was going to be one
franchise on mars that might be the one
reza i'm i'm not the person for the job
i'm really not in any way shape or form
you seem adventurous no i'm like in um
in a ferris wheel and i get
claustrophobic being
uh a pie in a ferrous wheel and you know
if i fly in like a small plane like one
of those commuter planes with like 20
seats
i i start to
to quiver and shake and sweat and me
sweating it's not attractive it could it
could put the rest of the team in danger
it really could i would move to
projectile vomiting if they could inject
me with something and put me to sleep
and i just like up surgery
and then you wake up on mars
okay i would consider that i would
consider that here's how i would
consider it if i was in my 70s
and i would be like i'm gonna spend my
waning years on another friggin planet
that's going to be cool that's pretty
cool but what good would i be to any
mission at age 74 what i want to know is
like what exactly would be your role on
that team
like you're the like the comic relief
yeah i would tell stories about steve
carell i would just it would only be
like what was your favorite uh cold open
prank with jim on the office
i would just listen worth it here's what
i would say here's and i think this is i
love that we kind of ended on this point
with dr mu which is that
we
study mars we explore mars we visit mars
not so we could live on mars but so that
we could live on earth and i think that
that
that's a beautiful thought and it's and
it you know i think it's sort of
reformulates the way that we even think
about space or exploration because you
know you and i we grew up on star trek
and star wars sure you know space
exploration is all about let's go there
and she's like no no
let's go there so that we could come
back and fix this and i think that that
in the end is kind of the best way to
think about it that really truly shifted
my perspective on what nasa does and
what jpl does and what um and the
importance of stressing you know
interplanetary uh
missions just for
for the data for the science and um much
of it will be
imminently usable so tell us oh dear
listeners would you go to mars would you
colonize another planet even if it was a
one-way trip is that something
that you would do like i would do in my
20s but not in my let's just say 40s mid
late 40s
it's got milkshakers so we've mentioned
this many times before uh we said if you
go
and rate and review our show on apple
podcasts
say something nice about us
take a screenshot tag us on instagram
and who knows we might actually invite
you to come on the show
and discuss your life's big question and
many of you didn't believe us and so now
we have no choice but to actually prove
it to you guess what
we have someone here with us mariah
mariah
hi how are you
to uh metaphysical milkshake
uh my life's big question
oh wow i've been pondering it for a
while and i started listening to your
guys podcast and i was like you two are
the perfect too to answer my question
hit us here we go
all right so my life's big question is
is it ethical to have a child or
children in today's society
i question this all the time because
there's so many factors from
an individual perspective
uh the political culture or the
healthcare system where one lives and
then on a global perspective
overpopulation food shortages and of
course the big one climate change the
impending end of the world as we know it
yeah is it an ethical decision for a lot
of millennials this is uh a lot of folks
feeling like
why why are we going to have kids now
what hope is there for the future you
know generation after generation there
was always hope of like oh next
generation it's going to get better you
know the economy is going to get better
racism is going to get better social
ills are going to get better medical
science will improve suffering will
reduce etc and this is kind of the first
generation in a long time that is kind
of like
wait a second things are actually
getting worse yeah so is it ethical to
have to bring a child into a world that
is getting worse it's a fantastic
question and you know you know you know
what the answer is
i have no idea but i bet reza does
well let me ask you this is a thing that
i i thought about a lot i think when i
was younger
and even when i met my wife
uh i was definitely in the
the fewer kids the better camp uh for
all the reasons that you were saying but
also some like you know life reasons
like wanting to have one for instance
um
but yeah i mean this whole notion of
we're leaving the world the worst place
for our children uh the future is bleak
um
you know the cost to the planet um
you know overpopulation all of those
things were stuff that i really really
thought about
and then
uh
since that time i've had four children
and
and
my my thinking on this has evolved and i
by the i completely respect you know the
people on the other end of the of the
aisle you know people like rain with
their one child so easy so easy it's not
even parenting i mean i bet you take
naps don't you rain
hey reza every day
things called naps i remember them
refreshing naps
and i'm being a hundred percent honest
here i'm not being facetious at all
mariah
i've come to kind of
the opposite viewpoint which is that
the world is [ __ ] and it's getting
shittier the planet is on fire
and so in a weird sense
it's like
all i can really rely on
is my family unit
so i think of my family which is now
with my wife six people
i think of us as kind of like
this clan you know like sometimes i have
these
post-apocalyptic fantasies you know
where we're like living on a burned out
uh planet uh on a hill a quiet place
yeah exactly like a quiet place and we
have to be really really silent which is
impossible for my twins to do um so we'd
probably be [ __ ] very early on in that
movie but nevertheless
and it's like
here we are it's like the olden days
it's like we're colonials like you know
living off the land uh you know except
trying to shoot zombies that are trying
to get into our our property line uh but
but i'm not joking i mean i really do
think of it as like
the the the last bastion of salvation
in this planet is me and my four kids
and my wife
and it's like
i've gone from thinking of it as a
family and and instead now thinking of
it as like a clan a unit in preparation
for the end times
i sound a little bit crazy i mean we
don't have it's not like we're end
timers now hold on a second here hold on
a second i thought when you were going
to be when you were beginning i thought
you were like going to be like
you know but but i made the choice along
with my wife to have these children
because we were going to instill in them
a love of humanity they were going to
save the world a better place and that
together we were going to work to
improve conditions for the poor and the
instead you're like no we're a clan
we're a clan we're in our cave and we've
got our deer jerky and we've got our
thigh bone clubs and we're just our clan
and we're just gonna watch netflix and
protect our cave god damn it
the worst human impulse
my first most ancient human impulse
planishness i know
kind of a kind of a clandishness that
you deride on your twitter feed
constantly
evolving we're de-evolving we're going
back into our cave
going i like how you brought that up
because one thing i think about is you
know apocalypse like but do you want to
have to
take care of a child through that or and
how many very good you know like a very
very good point but look
i'll be honest first of all i think
jessica would definitely be in that in
that category my wife is is like well
but our children are gonna save the
world and so that's that's her
philosophy and she's not wrong
um but i will say like
this kovid
pandemic was a little taste
you know just a teeny little taste of
that and it was like it was hard for
everyone i know it's very very difficult
but for us it was like the six of us
with the doors locked inside the house
18 months it was like a little bit of a
prep session for the coming zombie
apocalypse and i got to be honest with
you
it was pretty [ __ ] fantastic
just the six of us
now mariah what about you what are you
what are your thoughts here this is a
question that's been eating away at you
do you have any
have you do you have uh a strategy for
this one or is it something that keeps
you up at night
um it still keeps me up at night i'm
constantly um trying to figure it out
honestly i used to be on the side of no
i don't think it's ethical
because of
overpopulation climate change why bring
more people to the earth to take up more
resources to in possible eventual
end anyway
um but honestly i listened to like your
podcast with dr alby
and that gave me hope you know that
children growing up now are equipped
with different
tools to make it through their life and
to make that change so
that gave me a hope and then your
podcast with elizabeth colbert when she
talked about manipulating the
environment to our advantage i mean if
that's possible and people can have
children to raise them and do these
great things then absolutely you know so
i can see both sides of it and that's
why i thought you know you guys would
like it because
there's it can go either way really
to reference uh naomi klein who was our
guest talking about creating the next
generation
of
change agents in the world so
that's got to be a factor to add to the
education of a child which is
um hey the world is going to pot in a
lot of ways it's also getting better in
a lot of ways as well we can look at
both of those things um they're kind of
happening simultaneously there's a
disillusion and a unification happening
at the same time but we have to equip
our children to be ready for that and
and to fight for justice and to fight to
make the world a better place
yeah in all earnestness is that
a kid you know
it's a cliche it changes everything
it does change everything but one of the
things that it most definitely changes
is your
perspective on the world you know like
when it's you
it's hard to think past your own life
right
um
and it changes your values it changes
your point of view it changes how you
respond to people in the world around
you and then once you have children
you're like oh my life now has been
extended you know by with their lives
and so the things that i do now
i need to do in order to preserve
their place in the world and the world
itself and it it does so many of my
actions are motivated by the fact that
i do want my children to be
you know the people who solve the
problems and i do want um the world to
be in a place that gives them the
opportunity to do so um so maybe that's
a little bit selfish you know in some in
some ways but it does
allow me i think to be much more
strident in
the
the way that i approach uh the care of
the planet the care of other people um
it's almost like you know one of the
things that all parents have is this
kind of nesting impulse that suddenly
happens like you bring the baby home and
like all you want to do is like nest
well it's almost like that the world
becomes the nest and so i i'm out there
trying to build the kind of world that i
want them to live in it's
you know not everybody needs that kind
of motivation some people just do it for
for other people's sake i suppose
but knowing that it's for my children
the people that i love more than
anything else in this world is certainly
an extra motivation
i just want to highlight your work reza
on this show my name is al which is
about an afghan translator and it's it's
a multi-camera kind of sitcom for a
large audience
and
man oh man has that show become like the
most relevant show on all of television
right now um it's
an afghani translator who served in the
war you know at home in the midwest
and
uh now this is a very very real it was
always an issue but now it's especially
real and that's part of your work i
think of making the world a giant nest i
love that metaphor by the way is to make
you know entertainment that also
opens people's minds to other realities
and ultimately creates a greater sense
of community and unity i appreciate that
just i mean no big deal but it's called
the united states of al but you know
it's fine
my name is al like my name is earl which
i loved by the way that was a great
movie
mariah does any of this help at all is
this any of this clarifying
no no it helps it helps i like seeing
all angles of it so thank you so much
for that wonderful question and for
calling in it's a pleasure talking to
you and best of luck with everything out
there in maine and in marriage yeah
congratulations thank you guys so much
it was great to meet you
you can find us on our socials at reza
aslan at rainwilson and of course at
metaphysical milkshake and remember to
follow rate and review metaphysical
milkshake on apple podcasts and wherever
else you listen to your podcasts and of
course you can also subscribe to
metaphysical milkshake on our youtube
channel so that you can
watch us having these incredible debates
you want to know what rayne looks like
when he embodies marvin the martian then
you're gonna have to subscribe to our
youtube channel because that's right we
will see you next week with the
intergalactic space modulator
see you next week
metaphysical milkshake is executive
produced by rayne wilson reza aslan and
colin thompson it's produced by safa
samezadeh yaz harris lane mick dimaria
hashem self and dj lubell cast media is
the production and distribution partner
it is edited by tyler newbold and audio
mixed by justin kyle original music is
composed by jeff tank
let's send ben affleck to venus that's
what's going to say if you were going to
send one of them senpai
[Music]
hey thanks for watching you guys for
more fantastic videos just like the one
that you watch please subscribe to our
youtube channel thank you